playlist I know what this is peace
welcome to the ice Kevin show episode
number eight I'm ready this is fun I've
got my tomato plant here and I'm going
to lead off with the question for you
guys that this might be part of a usual
segment now where I'm asking you
something Christina thing why my orchid
in the last video so now instead we have
something that looks way worse when I've
got this tomato plant that is almost
dead that I'm trying to survive I had it
I had it by the window and I think it
was getting too cold from the air is
getting wintry here in Toronto so I
bought it I brought it closer inside
under the lights and hopefully that
works you're keeping it nice and
hydrated but you have tomato plant care
tips to fix this thing to get a growing
so I get some nice cherry tomatoes let
me know okay do the questions only a
bucci rights in from the newsletter did
you see me in a horoscope this article
completely represents me in my situation
this is an article talking about
mediocrity could you please offer me
practical assistance this is a great one
the article is about living mediocre
lies a lot of us live medial collides
right we may have a dream to do
something but rather than then go out
and try we continue to live in
mediocrity we have this environment that
holds us back and we're scared to take
even a little step out I've had a lot of
conversations past week about about
sharing and trying and and just doing
something and this is big resistance and
the big fear and if you want to avoid
your mediocre lifestyle then you got to
change it up right if you keep doing the
same thing that you've been doing you're
not going to get any greater results
right that's the definition of insanity
right it's thinking that you're going to
get better results by doing the exact
same thing over and over and over again
so what I want you to do is for one day
one hour have a little bit of courage
have a little bit of boldness do the
thing that you know you
to do that you're afraid of and put it
out there if you if you're a
photographer put out your pictures if
you're a singer put out a cover song of
a band that just recently came up put up
something share and you know you may
think I've never done this before I'm
scared you know what do people will
people say what will my friends think
stop caring about other people stop
worrying about what they're going to
judge you on and just put it out there
and all you need is out one hour of
bravery of boldness to step outside your
comfort zone because unless you do that
you're going to continue to live in
mediocrity and doesn't sound like that's
where you want to be and I hope that's
not where you want to be and when you do
when you put that up when you share
something that you love that you're
trying to make a difference in the world
I want you to share with me to you get
some extra they'll ec love in on there
to keep it going thanks for the question
ok next up is one of my youtube viewers
Prem love you guys rights in to say sir
I have a good idea in mind alright let's
see what you got the idea which i have
is useful to people and saves time but
the problem is how do I get investors
from idea because I'm a low class person
so where should I go and present my idea
it seems like every episode we've got
somebody asking questions with these
limiting personal beliefs right so so
because you're a low class person you
adopt a low class mentality and that's a
difference because investors don't care
what your background is they want to see
an opportunity that they can make a lot
of money from right there's a lot of
people who come from high class
backgrounds that never get funded
because their ideas suck even though you
come from a low class background it
doesn't mean you have the low class
mentality and i would first off star
question do you even need the funding
right now this is maybe not what you
want to hear but when you are launching
a business that early stage that's the
worst time they get funded because
they're going to take a huge chunk of
your business because that's the
riskiest time to be involved what you
want to do is build moment bootstrap get
some customers get some feedback get
some momentum show that people are
actually to pay for what it is that you
have then when you go to invest
you're looking to raise marketing
capital you looking to raise expansion
capital it's way easier and they're not
going to care where you came from it's
funny when I was in the VC business we
had so many people I submit their their
business plans who were phd's and that
actually counted as a strike against you
the VCS that I was working with it you
were a PhD they thought that you were so
book smart and had no street smarts that
accounted against you for your business
right was one of those things like okay
he's a PhD so maybe we don't want to see
him right that that's that that's the
mentality of investor so it doesn't
matter where you come from doesn't
matter what your background doesn't
matter what country you're from or who
your parents are people want to see good
ideas we have a good idea and you're
executing against it you're saving
people time and money you can show me
not just tell me on paper but you can
show me people who are getting tangible
results from using whatever product or
service you have that's all you need
that's your ticket in you just got to
get on your hustle and start building
some momentum okay next question comes
from a twitter follower will AG Martel
who wrote in to say Adam and Carmichael
looking for an entertainment agent
thanks for responding keep up the
awesome job bro bro thank you for the
great question so i've had an agent for
i guess just over a year year and a half
something like that and finding the
agent is not that difficult right you
can you can do a google search and find
an agent how i found mine was actually
through somebody who's already at the
agency and i talked to you know their
client and said i wonder if this would
be a fit for me I wonder if I need an
ancient and what if that's the right
group for me and he opened up the door
but you can find these guys we do just
do a simple google search the hard part
is showing that you have something
worthwhile right that you have momentum
that you have traction because an agent
they make their money from selling you
right from selling you into a book deal
from getting you radio show deals TV
deals partnerships collaborations
whatever it is they take twenty to
thirty percent of everything that they
help sell for you they're out there
marketing you but you got to give them
something worth marketing and it's a
combination of one having great content
so I don't know what your area of
expertise is but you have to have strong
powerful opinions
that means something to people that move
people that you have this platform that
that you believe in will make the world
a better place how are you doing that
right you have to stand for something
and to you have already subtraction I
think they don't want to work with
people who are just starting up who have
zero traction zero momentum just like
book publishers or publishing agents
they don't want to work with first-time
authors who have no audience who have no
momentum behind them so you want to show
that you're you're killing it on Twitter
you know you've got YouTube videos if
you're if you're trying to get an agent
you got to be on YouTube you have to
have great videos showing you speaking
showing you doing your thing because
they can see hey this guy really knows
what he's talking about and you have
that traction so again the agent part of
it is not the difficult equation it's
having a case to show them that you have
something behind you both from a Content
point of view and from a traction
user-based momentum point of view all
right next up another newsletter reader
kijana who wrote in to say hey Evan hope
you're doing well myself I'm okay good
to know is it possible for a normal
person with no job to commence a
business without any source of income if
so how thanks dear friend for your
cooperation kijana that's a great
question and a lot of people have it in
their heads that in order to be
successful in business you have to have
XYZ right you have to have X amount of
capital you have to have Y might have
experience you have to have come from
you know certain education none of that
stuff matters you look at the most
successful entrepreneurs of all time go
look whoever your famous entrepreneur is
your favorite Davis entrepreneur person
you look up to and respect look at how
they started and chances are they didn't
come from a wealthy family they didn't
come from having a background right a
lot of these guys started with nothing
had all the odds against them but they
got on their hustle and they started and
there's a lot of people have all the
advantages in the world they they went
to the best schools and have rich
parents and and you know had all the
education and money behind them in the
world and they don't start anything it's
the guys who are hungry who make it and
so the how look at anything with
entrepreneur look at how they got
started they got
by starting it's not about what you
don't have is about what you do with
what you do have so whatever business
you're trying to get started you didn't
tell me here what kind of company you
want to start whatever it is find an
easy way to start start talking to
customers start servicing them if you
don't have money to launch a product
start with a service you don't need any
money to start you don't need an office
you don't need business cards you don't
need a phone line do you spend anything
just go out and start talking to
potential customers and give them value
get close to them get to know them get
to know what problems they have get to
know how you can help them solve those
problems start making some money and put
it back into your business and put it
into developing products and put it into
expansion and growth you know I did this
video on Mary it not too long ago Jay
Willard married Christine let's let's
pop that link up there he started as the
son of a poor sheep herder who you know
didn't finish his schooling who came
back to to from being a missionary came
back home and his father went broke he
had all the odds against him and he
invested in himself to say you know my
family the surrounding that I'm in right
now isn't conducive to me being a
successful entrepreneur because I have
no role models have nobody look up to
hear nobody in my family has ever done
it before we're poor were broke we're
raising sheep for a living you know I
wasn't supposed to finish my education
all the odds against him and he invests
in himself and just got started and the
plan that you start with isn't going to
be the planet and finish with so don't
worry about having the perfect plan and
instead get out and start doing find the
smallest way to start this business up
start talking to customers so making
some money in and grow from there but
start do something and when you do send
me a note I want to know what your first
step is commit commit and get this thing
going I believe okay next up instead of
a question i'm doing a shout out to
Thorat am on twitter is deck den thora
tim she is a sharer she is awesome i
recently put out a page on my website to
support artists I love artists I want to
support artists I want to help them with
their music their visual art whatever it
is I have a lot of ways that I help
artists because
artists create beautiful things that
make people laugh and cry and feel joy
and excitement and happiness and in the
world would be such a sad place without
art and so I put up this page and I put
it to my newsletter and said hey if you
guys are artists if you know artists let
them know let's find a way to
collaborate because I want to help give
them exposure and thora awesomely
tweeted that out she said hey artists if
you guys you know are interested check
out this page from Evan and then she
went out and she tweeted personally a
number of artists that she knew and her
network who might be able to collaborate
with me and send it out to them this is
this is important because you don't want
to just consume information right you
got to be on the lookout to help other
people as well she shared that page to
her audience which added value for them
and then she took the time to write to
individual people in her network who she
thought could benefit from it and
they're gonna remember right you gotta
you know thora I don't I didn't know
before this thorup we've communicated
please excuse my forgetfulness but I
remember you now because you're out
sharing awesome stuff right she's adding
guy with the people in her network you
kind of do the same thing you find an
article that you read that you find
interesting share with other people add
value to their lives right you could be
that person they continue to remember
and then the next time you know they're
trying to add value to somebody else's
life they're going to think thora thora
is amazing so shadow to you props
awesome work thank you so much alright
last question of the day comes from
another YouTube viewer 593 alpha rights
in to say hi I had a question about your
recommendations from it to job postings
is on odesk one public one private but
didn't notice where you explain why
willing you at the video going to post a
job now thanks hey this is awesome so I
believe that fundamentally the way
people hire our is broken does not work
and that's why people don't stick with
your business and that's why you hire
the wrong people and that's why you get
frustrated think i'm going to just do
this myself christina pop that video of
the egg the hiring process is broken
because entrepreneurs need to watch that
so part of what i do is when i'm posting
a job in this specifically the odesk
i'll post a public job and that's for
everybody right i'll post a job ad
people will apply and
then i'll post a private job and the
reason for doing that is because i don't
care about your resume I don't read your
resume I don't read your work experience
I don't read your references I don't
need any of that because that stuff to
me is BS because I don't care where you
work before I don't care how good your
resume looks that's not the skill I'm
hiring for I'm hiring for people who are
passion who love what they're doing who
want to work with me on my mission to
make the world a better place and
support a billion entrepreneurs and I
want people who are on fire and the best
way to do that is to actually work with
somebody and skip the whole process of
interviewing and and resumes and all
that because it takes up so much time
and then by the time you go through that
you've committed to somebody that you
really need to make the work out with
that person if it doesn't work out
you're screwed because you got to go all
the way back to the start again instead
instead of hiring them what one person
forcing to try to make it work and then
they quit on you hire lots of people at
the start so before we to resume before
i do any kind of interviews which i
don't really do ever anyway i will hire
people from my first job posting so that
first job posting will be one big long
ugly nasty paragraph in the middle i'll
put a question like how many Twitter
followers do I have you got to answer
that question right up front you don't
answer that question I'm not talking to
you I don't care how good your
references are your work experience from
there everybody who answers that
question I will create a private job and
hire them so it's all of the winners all
the people who who took the time to read
my job post and they actually cared
enough to read all the way through our
detail-oriented enough to find that
question the middle and then go and do a
little tiny bit of work to submit it to
me I'll hire them on a job that I think
should take them two hours to do that's
reflective of the job that they'll
actually be doing when they work for me
but I give them five hours to do it and
it's a private job because I'm only
inviting those people in who answered
that first question and out of that
group i'll have people who who fall out
who don't do the job who milking for the
full five hours instead of doing you
know doing an in de toutes i think it'll
take who don't work well with me who
asked a million questions who don't ask
any questions who make wrong assumptions
who aren't hustling and you learn by
working with them right by working with
the people in
that are relying on their resumes and
cover letters and interviews by working
with them you get a sense if they're
going to be a good fit for you or not
and and you'll end up letting a lot of
people go which is fine and you end up
with the best person often that best
person almost always is a person that
doesn't look fantastic on paper whose
resume isn't great whose work experience
isn't great but they are hungry they're
on fire they work well with you there
porn energy ideas fuel into you to make
that project take off and those are the
kind of employees we need to have and
that's why you have two job postings one
private one public believe thanks for
another episode love you guys so much
let me know about the tomato plant I
need the feedback leaving the questions
below the comments tell me how to make
this thing live and be awesome thank you
guys so much for watching once where is
like this subscribe to the channel I
will see you soon fly my try to check
out my newsletter ya gotta laughing hi
I'm Jason j-rod fonseka of Ra's online
com and i want to say Evan Carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun inspiring
and it's deep only newsletter i
prioritize and look forward to period